Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcasts and
just checking in on you.
Just chicken and Anya chicken in Anya.
Jay help man. I need your help. Guess
what I have, I have the iPhone seven.
Oh
yeah.
Well what are you going to comicon
bill? What do you, when you got,
what do you got all of
the latest technology for?
I'll tell you why I was fucking
making some God damn fucking potatoes and
I had my fucking iPhone to the side on
the sick and water splashed
around and it got in,
it got in it somehow and then
the thing just went below a hoe.
Just fucking shut off. Right
as I realized it, I thought I,
you know the fucking counter tops. I
didn't see it. I fucking set it down.
This little was in a rush fucking,
you know,
peel potatoes like a fucking God damn
Mick. I Dunno what the fuck I was doing.
And I looked over and watched a couple
of dishes and I always lose sight of
where my phone is. It was near the sink
and there was water from, you know,
all of those pots and pans and stuff,
sprays and it was just sitting
in a fucking puddle and uh,
and my wife was just like,
shut it off, thrown in a bag of
rice, you know, it was like mash,
the happy ending and the thing
just fucking died. And, uh,
I didn't save any of my contacts,
you know, I, I didn't have,
I have had zero phone numbers.
I lost all my photos and all
my video for my European run,
my trip down to a mall fee. I lost
fucking everything, all kinds of shit.
I lost a picture of my fucking Ludwig
Drum Kit when I played at the Roxy and I
just did shit that I lost. I didn't even
want to fucking think about it. And uh,
but you know what, most
of it, I forget anyways,
it's like all that clutter that
you got your fucking house,
all the magazines you saving, you
never get to go back to them. You know,
if somebody actually snuck in your
house and took half of it, you know,
other than the space, you wouldn't
miss it, right? So this is my thing.
I know a lot of you guys would think,
oh well why don't you just put it on the
iCloud? And she says, well, you know, uh,
I don't know if I said this because I
had to start this fucking thing twice.
Yeah.
I don't want somebody at fucking,
I just don't want somebody else
having my shit. I mean, is,
is that so what can you fucking imagine
like back in the day, if somebody,
older people, you remember when
you had your little black book,
all your fucking phone numbers member,
all your family photos, your slides,
can you imagine if some corporation guy
will hold onto these, should be there?
Fuck you, will you Weirdo? What
are you doing with them? So,
and the reason why I never backed him
up to my computers because I could never
figure out how to do it. I mean, I, I
googled it and all that shit and says, go,
go in the iPhone section
of your iTunes.
Click on the Info fucking tab.
I can't wear it.
I have no fucking idea where it is.
I've looked up on all these things.
There's no video of it. Does all these
Shinay had to go iPhone to iPhone?
I found an ad iPad asked the fucking,
they've got everything except pop for me
to put my fucking phone numbers in the
contact book,
which I could do a few phones ago.
I know you guys think I'm a fucking moron.
I know you think I can't read.
I know you think I suck at reading out
loud and you know what? You're right,
but I'm not at the age where I used to
know how to do shit. Now I don't. Okay.
Give me a little bit of credit.
I'm only 48 years old.
I'm at 78 88 that's when
that shit creeps on. Okay.
I knew how to do this shit.
It used to be fucking easy.
You just do it automatically.
You just fucking plug it in and then
all you fucking knows we're on your
computer now.
Now they've,
they've made it really fucking difficult
in the amount of times. I just thought,
just given, given given
bad, put it on the cloud.
Let the ghost of Steve Jobs handle
it. Fuck that guy. Fuck that guy.
There's a reason why
God took him so early.
He needed to fucking slap
him around first. Okay?
He needed a yank that fucking
turtleneck right up over his head.
Jesus Christ built the man is dead.
He had children. I don't give a fuck.
I can't figure this out. Okay,
so people have to get hurt. Okay.
Oh,
I felt good.
So if anybody knows where the
fucking Goddamn fucking Info Tab is
in the iPhone section of fucking
iTunes and can explain to me how,
how the fuck I can save my own phone apps.
I actually went into Barnes and nobles.
It's a bookstore.
Everybody for anybody under the age of 40
they used to sell books. They still do.
And they're all,
my God.
What a collection of fucking human
beings that are in that place.
The last of the last, the last
of the book readers, right?
Like the last of the blacksmiths,
the last of the people with the
crank start fucking cars, you know.
Last of the Mohicans,
right.
Last person to take his shit and CBGBS
before they turned it into a John fucking
Barbados.
All right.
I am gave you some examples. I can't
even, what the fuck I was talking about,
but all I know is uh,
I need your help. Okay.
I don't know.
I went into the fucking Barnes and
nobles or is it Barnes and noble?
I don't even know. Once I see
Barnes, I'm like, uh, yeah, it's it.
What does it Benny Barns guys,
a fucking drug dealer.
He's either in jail or is hide.
[inaudible] Nicky Barnes.
I don't fucking know Benny Barnes.
Who the fuck was Benny Bart?
Was that one of the cats on top cad.
Okay.
It wasn't John Leguizamo's. Benny
Blanco. Benny Blanco from the Bronx.
The fuck was Benny barge.
He was somebody that's too cool name and
not have been somebody that is somebody.
Anyways, we'll get back to that. When
I looked that one up later, if I,
if I still know how to
fucking turn my computer on,
God knows on the new operating
system, maybe that changed. Um,
so I walk into this fucking bookstore and
I walk up to this, this woman, you know,
who's just like one of these
people who probably, she's,
she's the one who should be running the
country. All right? But she's, you know,
cause you know,
but she's not going to it because she's
a good person because she probably
doesn't like telling people what to do.
She probably doesn't feel qualified.
All right.
Unlike those two complete
fucking psychos that you mean,
can you imagine if the two of them
had a kid, if Trump fucked Hillary,
what would come out of that
fucking pre presidential snatch?
I can't even fucking imagine
the lack of feeling while,
and it would have black eyes.
Yeah.
Whatever it had.
And you'd look over and
it would be sitting on the
swing just staring at you and
you would be fucking horrified.
Um,
so much of this has to do with the fact
that I can upload my contacts. All right?
So don't take it too, too
personally. Um, but um, anyways,
by the way, uh, you know what I,
I barely noticed because I'm just like
every other fucking mouth breathing more
and just watching the football season,
did you notice how there's
like no pink in the NFL?
Like they toned it down
over the last three years.
That kind of fucking tapered off.
Isn't that amazing?
And you know why that is right?
Because the NFL raise so much
money for cancer awareness.
They put such a debt and the
disease that they don't even,
they don't have to do it anymore.
That's what happened. Okay. That's,
that has to be what happened.
Cause if that's not what happened,
then I guess the NFL doesn't care about
finding a cure for cancer anymore.
Dead. There's no fucking way that's true.
It's kind of weird how that happened.
Kind of weird how fucking went all the
way the fuck up and then it just kind of
tapered the fuck off and people are
still getting cancer left and right.
This kind of weird. I thought
that that was like, yeah,
I thought they were all about the
family's support and the tropes.
Charging them for those pictures.
Right.
Support and the fucking troops
and all that. Those fucking cops,
they got in bed with that pink lady.
They all got their yachts.
People are starting to figure out like,
hey, where the fuck is all this money go?
You know where it's going.
Okay.
It's going down to the pick Twat fucking
strip club and all the owners go down
and they fucking bang away while
their wives are fucking, I dunno,
driving around in their pink
fucking caddies, they stepped away.
The NFL stepped away.
They just backed up.
They just slowly fucking backed
out of the room, you know?
Now they just got a little pink
fucking thing on the, on the,
this is all my conspiracy theory. They
just have little pink thing on the field.
You know,
let's say it's a maybe 30 paces around
next year it'll be 15 this it is going to
gradually disappear. Yeah.
And then maybe one guy in,
in October in the NFL will get Pinkeye
and that'll be the last fucking thing.
And they'll just, they'll just, Joe just
fucking step away. They made their money.
They're going to let that lady take
the heat. You know what I mean?
They gonna play babe in the fucking woods.
All we did know,
we thought it was on the Fuckin Bull,
but the, you know what you were doing,
you took all that fucking
big money, you cuts. Um,
got it being such a great mood. If I could
just fucking, you know what's great is,
is today the amount of the
amount of fucking phone
numbers I've got to tell you,
having not used the iCloud any,
the only fucking number that I knew other
than mine was, was my wife's. That's it.
I knew nobody else's,
you know.
Okay.
Trying to think if there's
even like a commercial on TV.
Was that one? Hey date, hate, hate, hate,
hate, hate that fucking phone number.
The seven seven's a car.
[inaudible] I know that one. Um,
it's a car service in New York, I believe.
I don't know if they're still around.
I think they are like the
only ones that I fucking knew.
MMM.
But I mean I got like, I got
like a fucking, I swear to God,
I feel like you've got a hundred
phone phone numbers back already.
Let's go into the old fucking iPhone
seven which for some reason you got to buy
this umbilical cord in order
to this little mini umbilical
cord that's 10 bucks,
10 bucks for this little fucking thing
that you know you're going to loose if
you're like me.
I mean I,
I've probably bought in 15 fucking
charges for every phone that I have.
I always lose them. I always leave him.
And those things are actually, you know,
they're long enough. They're like
an amaze. She hated garter snake.
I mean I shoot with a big fucking head,
you know what I mean?
Like I shouldn't be losing those,
forget about this little thing. I mean,
I don't think it's longer than an inch.
So the problem is,
is that now with the new ones,
I guess when you charge them,
you can't listen to your music,
which of course is just a major
problem for everybody, including me.
Forget about all these political
prisoners around the world.
Forget about the children that's so
together. You're flashy fucking clothes.
Let's talk about how us in the first
world can now not plug our phones and
charge them while listening to our music.
Okay. I know it's a first world problem,
but of course it is.
I live in a first world.
MMM.
Jesus fucking Christ. Let me see how
many fucking context I had already.
I put that guy's name in wrong.
Got To fucking fix that one.
I've just been obsessed all
fucking day long. All Day long.
Just just everybody who
I had to take every call.
Like once you lose all your contacts,
you don't know who the fuck's calling you.
It's like, Jesus, I got to call this
guy. What if? What if? This is what?
This is the guy calling from the thing.
What if something amazing is
going to happen? You know?
And it's just the same old bullshit
fucking phone calls. Let's see here.
All right, done. All
right, then you hit this.
So the new thing about this one is it's
fucking waterproof, which is great. Oh,
by the way,
okay.
If you want to get a,
there's a Belkin lightening,
3.5 meter adapter, B, e. L. K. I. N.
They're 15 bucks.
And if you get one of those,
you can charge it and listen
to your music at the same time.
So they have filled the void,
the proverbial void created.
Um, was it done on purpose when we return?
All right, so let's see what I got here.
How many fucking phone knows
do I have here? One, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
eight. You know what? I'm gonna hit pause.
I'm going to count these fuckers and
let you know. All right, I'm back.
Quick count hundred 13 phone,
phone numbers recovered.
Okay.
Recovered in fucking in Lynn
in 24 hours then ain't bad.
I'll get another hundred tomorrow,
you know?
But there are some that I'm just like,
Oh fuck,
I'm never going to get that guy's
number. You know what I mean? You got to,
you know, when you lose all
your numbers, there's like,
rather than just trying to get to
everybody, you got to have hubs.
You gotta be like, all right, this guy,
he can give me five. Okay. And that one,
one of those five will
lead to another five.
And this thing is you can only hit
each person up for about five numbers.
Have you once in a while you find
a fucking sweetheart, which I did.
And she'll give you a zillion of them.
My wife gave me a Zillion, uh, you know,
the woman that I put the Patrice
O'Neal benefit together with.
She gave me a bunch and,
um,
I'll just kinda keep going and
going and going and going as a,
as we get this thing together. But, um,
I lost all the photos and,
uh, you know what I think, uh,
I think I'm all right with it. Whatever.
You know what? I got him up here, man.
Got Him up here. The gray is hard
drive ever, man. You brain. Um,
I keep threatening. I keep
threatening to get a flip phone again,
but I can't because everybody is just,
you know when you run
your own fucking business,
even if that is shit jokes and everything
and people are sending you emails and
you have to sign shit and scan shit,
it's at some point you got to have one
of these and I also love having all this
fucking music on it. I really
do. Oh, that's another thing too.
When I plugged my new fucking iPhone
and I lost like half my music.
How does that happen? I don't
know. Is it a, is it in the cloud?
Is it on the stars with a
fucked it all my music go.
I had every fuckin ACDC album. Now I have
like four. Where the fuck did they go?
Oh I know.
I'll call somebody up at iTunes and I'm
sure I'll get them on the phone shortly
and they'll, they'll help me
out with it. Fucking hostile.
Can't she can't get to anybody.
You know what,
this is one of this was blessed would
be what it really fucking feels like as
you grow older is you just feel the
world cares less and less about you.
You just like this old horse ready for
the glue factory and that we can't make
any money off this guy. Just this guy
can't carry anything. My fuck them.
And you just sit.
Yeah,
there were,
I can I get anybody on the phone,
you know, like, you know what I'm really
feeling bad for right now is Hugh Hefner,
you know,
you have,
there was and always will be
the fucking man. All right.
And he recently, he had to, you know,
he had the magazine and
because of new technologies,
nobody's buying magazines anymore.
They tried to revamp.
They tried to keep up Babababababa
online porn, all this fucking shit.
They just couldn't keep up. And uh, he
ended up having, I think having a s,
I don't know what he had to fucking do.
All I know is he put his house up for
sale and part of the sales price was,
you know, that he was gonna
live in the house until he dies.
And then you get it and you can do
whatever the fuck you want. And I oh man,
what a fucking this bit.
I gotta tell you something man.
Okay.
I said this to, to, I ate
Nia to, I'm going to forget how I said
it. I was just talking about Los Angeles.
Los Angeles is an extraordinary
lonely place to die in
and less, but he does have kids. So
I think we'll be all right. You Dude,
if you fucking just,
if you just,
if you go out here and you make some
money and you get some fucking whores and
you get some blow and you
take the fucking ride,
you know what goes up,
comes back down.
And when you come fucking back down and
that you got no cartilage left in your
nose, right. And your fucking
hairpieces fucking flopping around.
I mean that and then, then you just
sit in there and whatever's left.
Uh, yeah house. That used to be the shit.
Now you're sharing it with somebody else.
Right.
And you sit in there slowly dying.
No one I'm dying and then no one in the
background here in the cars going by.
Right. And just knowing it's
going to keep going without you.
They're going to keep making movies.
They got to keep,
there's going to be beautiful women and
then I could have fucking it's over.
It's over for you. I hope you had a
good fucking time buddy. All right.
I know it's fucking more, but if
shit, but you know, I can't get my,
I can't get my phone numbers.
You'll be fucking hilarious as
if you went country to country.
What's your biggest fucking
problem and uh, you know,
or like neighborhood to neighborhood,
you know what I mean?
All this black lives matter shit and
I'm fucking sitting here. I can't yeah,
get my fucking phone.
Okay.
It's people with diseases is war torn
countries and I am throwing literally at a
48 year old man having a fucking shit
fit cause I can't get all these fucking
people's any, what's funny is,
is pretty much at this point,
I have everybody's phone number,
I got all my friends,
I got all my family pretty much.
I got all of that and I got
my business context and uh,
okay.
I Dunno,
you don't some worst thing about losing
all your numbers is you lose all those
do not answer once, you
know, fucking psycho,
don't pick up.
You know all of those ones,
Jesus Christ and I, I have
to pick up, I, I'm, I,
I'm one of those I got to pick up. I'm
like, oh what if, what if this is a,
what if this is Steven Spielberg and he's
doing a reboot, a VT and he wants me,
he wants me to play 80 he wants me to
fucking crouched down and I'd fucking do
it too. I do it. I don't
give a shit. You know what?
Stick me in a fucking movie, Gag, go.
Whatever the fuck you need me to do there.
Stevie,
you know,
you want me to sling the mud
around as I'm looking at a volcano?
Is this some flying saucer playing some
fucking music? I will do that in a cell.
That's the lead.
I never understood that
movie close encounters.
I wanted to see it so bad when I
was a kid, when I finally saw it,
I was just like, that's it.
That was the fucking movie
that, that really look
hastily put together. You know
what I mean? Like I don't,
I don't fuck,
maybe I got to watch it again.
Maybe I'm just a football
watch and fucking moron.
But when I watched that movie in Richard
Dreyfus is just sitting there like
listening to this, whatever that
like, it was like a Simon says,
but it was a flying saucer going like,
hey booboo, BBB. But he's going like,
wait a minute man,
wait a minute.
And he's throwing like fucking
mud at this, this volcano.
And somehow he gets it. He gets
what the fuck's going on? And uh,
I don't even remember the end of the
movie. I, you know, I don't remember most,
what the fuck do I get off criticizing
a movie, having never made one.
Right like that. Like being the
director and the creative force.
I never fucking did that shit
and I can't remember how it ends.
That's not gonna stop me from
criticizing it. I didn't like it too.
Freckle thumbs down,
close encounters of the third kind.
There's a lot of fucking movies that
have done really well that I just don't
understand. You know, there's the
classics like chariots of fire.
I don't know who the fuck that was for,
but when I sit down and I saw that movie,
I could literally smell the house of the
person that liked that movie because I
had a paper route and I knew what
those kinds of people smelled like.
You know what I mean?
They just,
the heat was going to be on too high and
it was going to have that musty smell
of someone beginning to die.
You know, you know that, oh,
there is an old person odor
and it's so you have a meeting,
you have a meet somebody who's like almost
your age and they already have it and
you just look at it and I'm like, do
they realize they're were already dying?
It's, I don't if PSAs smell
it, the cake, you know,
how does that happen? I mean, Jesus
Christ, that's like a fucking car.
If you don't start it up every day saying,
I don't know. Is that what happens?
I don't fucking know. All I know is
Tom Brady. Tom Brady's coming back.
Okay. And also, Oh shit.
Starting tomorrow night,
take me out to the ball game.
Take me out to the crowd.
I don't give a fuck about the first one.
62 I show up in October.
Oh whoa.
That's what I do.
And I root root root
for the fucking red sox.
If they don't win,
it's a shame.
But they are already beat the cursor,
the babe and everyone Mozhan
rights. Right. That's why I left.
I left in 2010 I left in 2010 with
baseball. I was just like, look,
either fucking get it out of
the game or make it legal,
but stopped getting me excited about
shit that you can say five years later.
It doesn't come. I still love the game.
Who Doesn't love somebody? I, you know,
I love a picture still. That's how much
I love baseball. I like to keep score.
I like all of that. But, um,
I know from 98 to 2010 there was just
too many fucking people that I was just
like, Holy Shit, Whoa Lee Shit Dude.
I'm watching a guy who is fucking with,
you know,
the greats of the Goddamn game. And
then the, and then like, you know,
five years later I actually,
he was parked,
Sentara had I done,
it doesn't really count that as shitty
or should they not be in the hall? Right.
But then you had like,
you know,
people like Alex Rodriguez come
along and they fucking like, I mean,
they've got most talented
fucking do it all, you know,
and all of a sudden it's like,
oh,
he's on steroids and the
big fall of him or whatever.
And then I love the guy comes back,
he gets a 600 home run in. I'm in,
I'm in New York City
in this video of this,
cause I know I posted it
somewhere on the cover.
They were given shit for the Patriots.
One of the trumped up fucking horseshit
ticky tack charges of US cheating.
And then on the back they were given
Alex [inaudible] rig is love for hitting
his 600th home run.
It's only cheating if the other
team does it. Um, so anyways,
I'm very excited for playoff baseball,
you know,
that's my favorite time.
Everybody's all bundled up.
They get the extra microphones at the
ballpark. Joe Buck's calling the game.
What's not to like the
Games fucking matter.
Yeah.
Of the four major sports,
there was not a fucking sport out there
where it matters worse if you lose a
game when there's 160 fucking two of them.
It just,
it doesn't fucking matter.
You know, and, and I,
the fucking slave labor that these people
have to go out and play 162 fucking
games is just like, I
mean, baseball's got it.
How the fuck does football
make more money than baseball?
You would just think collectively like
during the height of the steroids era,
which is is a great argument for steroids.
I mean the ballparks were packed,
you know what I mean?
I think you know all of these people
around the world who are just confused at
why America could give
a fuck about soccer,
right?
Or feet ball is what it should be called.
You know what I mean? I love whoever
the fuck came up with that on Twitter.
Cause what do you call football and you
can pick it up. Well why do you call,
what do you call it? Football. You can
use both feet, right? And then feet ball.
You want to be a cunt? We can be
a cunt to right. This is a deal.
If they would just fucking
roid these fucking players up.
Okay,
we're there at at center ice,
but it's a field and they could just
tee one up and fucking blasted into the
back like fucking album again.
It's back at the day at the Blue Line.
You know what I mean?
Fucking Paul Coffee Skate down towards
his old goaltender, widen it up,
go and fucking top shelf. If they
had some people fucking doing that.
Somebody said that to me one time
I was in Fenway and then we were talking
about how we're just not into soccer
and the dough just goes, well we
have soccer here. It's, it's, it's,
it's called hockey and it's a lot faster.
And whenever I watched soccer,
like I see that I look,
I understand there's a beauty to
that game and everything, but, uh,
you know what the reality is, is I just
don't have time to watch another sport.
I mean, I've gotten a little behind
with the f one, you know, um,
I haven't seen the Malaysia race yet,
but I, I was able to go back and,
uh, I watched the Singapore race, which
was cool as shit cause it was at night.
MMM.
And then I watched the beginning,
it was at the beginning of the Malaysian
race would that fucking Hackenberg guy
just got fucking hit and the whole
side of his car got taken out.
What a fucking buzzkill that is.
Um,
okay.
But anyways, I know Nico's, no, he
came in third place. That's right.
And then force India, didn't they win
the first to spot? I gotta look it up.
What was it, the red bull team. I
don't fucking know. But um, anyways,
I think Japan's next and then do
they go to Austin, Austin, Texas.
I think that's what it is. Yeah.
Which that's, I obviously don't,
I should probably go to that one next
year. Book Myself Out there in Austin.
Go out there.
Right.
Check it out.
Stock car racing.
Yeah.
Um, anyways, what the fuck am I talking?
I'll whipped of 25 minutes here.
I don't have any of the
advertising but um, I am actually,
I'm flying out to Atlanta,
um, later on tonight,
taking the red eye out and I'm
working the Fox theater in Atlanta.
Uh,
tomorrow night with Paul Versey guess is
going to be tonight when you listen to
this.
Paul Versey,
Joe Barton neck and then a good friend
of mine from the original punchline
Atlanta and they've just reopened. Jamie
Bendel is going to come out and mc it,
bring up the acts. We're going to
have a great time. And then, uh,
then we're going down to Gainesville
and I don't give up. Let me tell you,
I don't give a fuck.
All right about this God
damn tropical fucking storm.
Is that all it is at this point?
Because they've their fucking,
and this is the thing,
this sitting there on these weather
channels and they're showing people from
2005 buying up all this bread they use
using stock footage of people freaking
the fuck out. All right? And they're
saying like, you know, we did,
there's so many of these warnings
that people, they've, they've,
they've come become complacent. They be
completely, they like blaming people.
It's like, no, because you
can't have trick these people.
You've cried wolf so many fucking times.
And I know you have to warn the general
public that there's something coming,
but the way that they do it,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
They just have this riveting footage
of people getting washed out to force.
They don't get washed out to sea. There's
always some Douche fucking surf into.
Yeah.
MMM
know they scare the fuck out of people.
And there's only so many times
you can end up, you know,
just getting a regular rain shower and
you have like fucking six weeks worth of
of of milk in your refrigerator that
you just going to be, ah, yeah. Yeah.
That's like them freaking us
out about the fucking yell.
The next giant earthquake is coming out
here. That's the funniest thing ever.
So what exactly am I? It's a fucking
earthquake. Should I go with, is no earth.
What am I going to leave my
shit like when you moved to La,
you know you're rolling the dice.
You're basically rolling the dice.
I can make enough fucking money.
All right,
I can make my mark and then I can get
the fuck outta here before this thing
breaks off.
It's ups.
You're basically Wiley coyote looking
over the edge of a fucking cliff.
You know what I mean?
As the roadrunners coming by and
you know what's going to happen,
you're a little apparatus. You can jump
on the stick. The rock goes up in the air,
it hits the fucking part of the
clip you're on in the year you get,
you're going to go down.
Right.
You're just hoping that it
doesn't happen during your time.
It was probably a bad example,
but you know, I'm, I'm, yeah,
I'm not the brightest guy.
I mean,
I can't even upload my context
under my fucking computer,
but I know after this podcast, I will be
able to, cause I've reached out to you,
the common man, the person,
the common lady on Twitter.
And you know what I love about
you guys. I know, you know,
you're going to teach me how to do it,
but you're gonna,
you're gonna hate your stupid
freckled fuck blah, blah, blah, blah.
You can give me all, and I don't
give a shit. I'm gonna fucking,
I will glide through those insults
to get to this information.
I've already wasted a fucking hour of
my life trying to figure out how to do
this, to avoid being in this
exact same fucking situation. Um,
I was actually, when I was at
the, uh, the fucking iCloud store,
they would have an iTunes store, the
apple store, right. I fucking go in there,
you know,
let's see if one of our geniuses,
they literally say it with a straight
face, one of these geniuses configure out.
But who's can, no, I can't figure
out how to do it. So in my world,
I guess they are a genius.
So this guy was cool as shit.
He goes to just store anything on the
ICLOUD and I go, well, not on purpose.
I might've clicked something by accident
and we just would just sitting there.
He goes, we'll click on this, wait a few
seconds. And he's like, ah, no, no, no,
no, no. Well maybe your
folders, maybe save she photos.
Click on that. And I'm like,
nothing. He goes, no, no, I'll wait a
second. Wait a second. Just wait a second.
See if something comes up. Yep. Nothing
there. And he goes, how can we, you know,
use the iCloud? And it doesn't have to
like, I was fucking creepy to me. He goes,
well, you know, it's a really
safe, totally secure system.
I go, yeah, until it isn't.
He goes, yeah, I know.
So, um, anyways, I'm very
excited to go to Atlanta.
That's where I take my last special.
I'm getting ready to do another special.
I picked out the fucking shirt I'm gonna
wear. It's a little nod to Nashville.
Um, little busier than old
fucking Frederick always used.
What the fuck? Why not every special
should have its own God. Damn. Look,
I'll wear a snazzy shirt for those
fucking cowboy. Fucking those,
those steer cow punching
fucking people down there.
Um, I am beyond ready to
do this fucking thing. Oh,
by the way, by the way, I got a call.
My car fucking showed up yesterday,
showed up yesterday,
the detail in it. Everything's going
to be fucking ready. All right.
And I pick it up. Uh, hopefully next
Monday when I get back, I come back,
I go out there, I picked this
fucking thing up. And, um,
so I'm taking my last
few rides with the Prius.
You what's funny about the fucking Prius?
All you guys shitting on
the fucking Prius, right?
Do you know what me fucking offers I've
gotten when I, I was buying a new car,
the amount of fucking people that have
asked me to buy that Goddamn car simply
because of the gas mileage. I got the
fucking side view mirror of fixed.
I got a,
I got to get the bumper fixed and then
I got to go get a detailed because of,
you know, all these years I have in
my fucking awesome dog, you know,
um, you know, she's a dog. She shipped.
Sometimes she doesn't smell as good.
Um, and evidently according to
my wife, when she gets nervous,
she admits and odor. She's never
peed or shit in the fucking thing.
But definitely when she gets fucking
nervous and I don't know what the deal is.
Um, yeah, but mentally she admits
a fucking odor or something.
Maybe that's what the fuck it is. I don't
know what it is, but there's definitely,
hey man, there's been a dog in this
car for like eight years. Right?
So I got to get that shampooed out,
uh, before I sell it to somebody.
I wouldn't do that to somebody. You
know what I mean? Fucking asshole.
He hit my God damn car right before I'm
giving it away. So I'm like, all right,
throw like the fucking 18th bumper on
this thing that I've had to get in.
Reality is probably like the sixth back
bumper, like every year, year and a half.
I got to get another one cause
someone fucking hits me. Um,
and uh, I took it over to
get the estimate, that guy go
slab. Actually, uh, I, there's probably,
I can tell by this dent,
you're probably going to need more than
a just a bub or see there's another
layer behind that
layer behind that layer. And then
there's the frame. And I was like, well,
I wasn't having problems closing
the hatchback, so I think it's out.
Know that will, I will, I'm not
going to know until I get back.
So the fucking asshole hit me and I
didn't even run it through my insurance
company. I just said, fuck
it. Fuck it. You know,
I'm not going to deal with that shit.
You know, go down there and then, and
then they're not going to say, and then
they go, well you didn't, you do this.
And what about this guy over
here? I just say, fuck it.
I use insurance companies for the
big things. You know what I mean?
Cardiac arrest, a near
death experience. You know,
some guy gets mad at somebody and
he slams a car that hits a card.
The den hits mine. I feel like that's
par for the course out here. You know,
I kind of wished the cops got there before
he just grabbed his bags and left his
car. Probably fucking stole
the thing. Who knows? Well,
this is the end of this
rambling horse shit. Uh,
you can listen to some
advertising after that.
Then there'll be a little bit of
music and then you listen to some, uh,
some clips from a podcast,
from a podcast gone by in a time
that's already happened. Um,
I want to thank everybody who tries
to help out me to help out me,
to help me out with this fucking thing.
Um,
if you're listening to this and uh,
you have my phone number, text me,
send me a fucking text,
cause chances, chances,
I don't have your fucking
number in my fucking iPhone seven.
I'm calling it right now. That little, uh,
umbilical cord that's
hangs off that thing.
I'm going to have to buy at least nine
of those before I buy the next one.
This is the first time I've gone from
like one number two, the very next number.
Like I kept the iPhone
four s until I got the six.
Um,
I had the three and then the iPhone four
came out and then I get the every other
one. I never had the five. I got to
six and I was like, fuck the seven.
You know, especially when people are
complaining about something new, right?
Like this one is so stupid to buy.
I would not buy this phone because what's
going to happen is they're going to
figure out this little appendage fucking
thing. They're going to figure it out.
And you know what?
They already have it
figured out.
They have the next nine complaints
already figured out and they don't give a
fuck. They just put it out
like this. So everybody could
be like old, you know, 89%.
Great, but what about this? Right? So,
um, you know, I wouldn't buy this one.
I would wait for the seven
s or possibly the eight.
That's what I planned on doing until I,
uh,
look making any mashed potatoes.
All right, go fuck yourselves.
Have a wonderful weekend.
You can't and I will discuss more
shit with you on Monday. All right,
have a great weekend.
Enjoy the advertising.
Whatever the fuck I get it.
All right, here we go. A little bit of
advertising there. All right. Siki week.
Oh Jesus.
Someone else's doing it.
Let's see if these people
don't go out of business.
Siki buying tickets online for sports
and concerts has been a confusing process
for a long time.
It's always been hard to find the best
deal for that game or show you you want
to go to. And none of these older
tickets sites wants to change that,
but seek geek is different.
They've come along,
create an amazing APP and website that
makes it easier than ever for fans to buy
and sell tickets.
Siki does all the pricing price comparison
for you by searching multiple tickets
sites and ensuring that you get
the best possible deal. See,
Keke does not does all the work
and you save time and money.
Jesus Isapro and seek geek wants to help
you get the most bang for your buck.
That's why every ticket on Siki
is given a grade based on value.
You'll immediately see any underpriced
seats and be able to find the best deal
that fits your budget.
Best of all,
my listeners get a $20 off rebate
for their first Siki purchase.
Nod To get $20 off, $20 rebate on
tickets. Download the seat APP,
go to the settings tab and click.
If you can find it at a promo code and
our Promo Code Bur bur are seek equals
send you $20 after you've made
your first ticket purchase,
download the SEATGEEK APP and
enter Promo Code burr today.
All. Here's the next one. Simply
say thousands of people get, uh,
seeking home security.
Get ripped off every day.
And the home security industry wants
you to believe it's your only option.
They got [inaudible] Oh,
who was no of salesmen out there.
Same thing trying to scare you into
signing one of their longterm contracts.
She gets stuck writing huge checks
month after month with no way out. Man.
It's robbery by contract contract
and it can cost you thousands,
but maybe hundreds if you
live in a trailer home.
But there's a better way to protect
your home. Simply safe home security,
simply safe, has no contracts,
none. You'll get award winning 24,
seven protection named best in industry
security professionals watching,
ready to instantly send the police.
Well,
why don't they do something
and it's just 1499 per month.
That's less than half of
what most companies charge.
Protect your home this smart way.
Well,
I guess for 15 bucks a month you
can't expect them to jump in the fray.
All right, these guys are cool. Uh,
protect your home. The smart way.
Visit simply safe bird dog chrom.
Go right now.
And you'll also get free shipping on
your order and a free key chain where 25
bucks. That's a hell of a key chain. It
takes only a minute. That's simply safe.
birth.com simply s I, m p l, I,
safe burg.com.
All right.
Oh it's track [inaudible] everybody.
Smart phones, smart cars, smart homes.
Technology has made
everything wicked smart.
But losing your phone still make
smart people feel wicked stupid.
Track tracker makes losing
things a thing of the past.
I should get one of these for
my phone hunting. Um, yeah,
she's really pissed at me right now.
Tracker is a coin size device that
locates misplaced keys, wallets, bags,
computers, anything in second. Just
pair tracker to your smartphone.
Attach it to anything. Find is precise,
precise location with the tap of a button.
It's just that easy. Lose
your phone. No problem.
Press the button on tracker and your
phone rings even when it's on silent.
Creepy with over 1.5 million devices,
tracker has had a fucked as it turn.
Your phone on.
Tracker has the largest crowd gps
network in the world. So your item,
your lost item shows up on a map. Even
if it's miles away, never lose anything.
Again with tracker,
listen to this show and get a special
discount of 30% off your entire order.
Go to the tracker.com and
enter the Promo Code Bird.
The hardest things you'll ever have
to find is going to be their website.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter
the Promo Code [inaudible] for 30% off
your entire order.
Again,
that's tracker t r a C K
e r.com Promo Code Burr
is
um, all right, lights, camera dumped bill.
I'm a 29 year old guy and
recently broke up with a funny,
attractive and all around.
Great girl. Oh Gee.
Why Sir would you do that?
You ask. All right, uh,
two things. Her Dad was born
without teeth and your words,
your baby will if you breed with her or a
is she has got something
going on in the vaginal area,
some sort of odor, sticky
pussy. I don't know. Oh, here
we go. Well let me tell you,
this girl and I had been dating for about
three months and we had a great thing
going. She's half Afro Cuban,
half Puerto Rican and really sexy.
She had a rough upbringing,
but I didn't care because she's honest,
easy going and not bitchy like so many
girls I've dated. She was a bit needy,
but I didn't mind.
Okay.
Um, we were out at a bar one night having
a few drinks and I was feeling pretty
good.
I was looking at a couple of floozies
at the end of the bar and asked her if
she's ever been with another woman.
She coyly looked at me and said yes.
Okay,
good stuff. I thought, yeah, dude,
this is a fucking fantasy right here.
Fucking red shoe diaries.
Um, then I proceeded with,
have you ever been in a threesome
with two girls and a guy again?
She answered yes.
Okay.
Okay. Kind of slutty, but I'm
no saint. While I couldn't stop.
They are God, you're going to
go for the rotisserie question.
What's in the box? Ah, here we go.
Here we go. Strap yourselves in for
this one. Well, I couldn't stop there.
So I asked, have you ever had
a threesome with two guys?
She looked down at the ground
and she looked up a bit ashamed,
Lee and said, yes. Wow. Skank alert.
I thought I then asked
her one more question.
I knew this one could back for
where the fuck do you go from here?
Like throwing the high heat to Elbert
Elbert pool hosts. I finally asked,
wait,
have you ever been in a porn?
She then blushed and look me
in the eye and said, yeah.
I looked at her calmly and was
like, oh, but inside I was like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yes. Well, you should,
you know those first couple.
I mean,
you can look at, let's, let's break this
down here. All right. She's been with, uh,
she's had a threesome with another
girl and a guy who get that.
That's who gives a fuck right there.
All right.
You're already knew she banged
another guy. All right. But, uh,
the fact that she also did it with another
girl that takes a little fucking, uh,
that tones down his dick in her pussy.
Right? This is how guys think. Women,
I'm sorry. All right. That's something
that, that's something in the, uh,
the credit is the credit. Uh, why, why,
why do you try to talk with counting shit.
You're too dumb. All right. That
one's all right. The two guys thing.
Now you can look the other way on that.
Maybe if it, if it was in another state,
but it can't be in the same state because
if you run into one of the two guys
that fucking, you know, we're high fiving
as they fucking banged her that, I mean,
I dunno about that one. But then the third
one she did a porno. I mean, yeah, no,
that's a,
you've got to walk away from that
or,
or you have to go to NASA to get tested
for the latest fucking STDs I would
think. And then also God
knows what's going on. Uh,
mentally that you would do
that. What? I just like sex.
No, now there's something going on.
Who doesn't like sex? I Dunno. Anyways,
plowing ahead. See, she's so, she egos.
So basically she had moved down
to Los Angeles when she was 20.
She's now 25 and after a
short stint in the military,
somehow she got into the porn industry
for eight months. She did everything.
Ooo,
Fox sucked the whole Shebang.
I asked her if I could see her video,
but she wouldn't tell me her
performer name and said Vietnam,
the that it would be impossible
to find her body of work.
I asked her why she got
into porn and she replies
because I wanted some feeling in
my life and then he rides dao.
Ji Ji is, yeah, dude. Oh, this poor
girl. Something happened to her.
The thing was she was clean,
had a good job and really liked her
and the sex was great. Yeah. Obviously,
you know what's funny,
there was something you wrote in the
beginning where I just thought she was
going to be good. 29 year old guy,
attractive all around. Great girl.
All the fact that you said
she had a rough upbringing,
but she was easygoing and honest and
not bitchy right there. I was like,
that girl's good in bed. It just
seemed like a kind of free open person.
I don't know. I didn't know. She was going
to be that open. Oh, Gigi. Um, anyways,
the thing was she was clean and I
have a blah and the sex is great,
but I couldn't stop picturing her in some
sleazy porno that was probably filmed
in some junk yard on labrea.
So I went to ask for friend's advice.
Most of my guys were telling me to dumper
my gay friends told me it was fabulous
and that I should overlook it.
I didn't even bother asking my girlfriends
because they would automatically
reject her and assume I had aids.
There you go. Keep your options open.
So regretfully I dumped her.
I felt terrible and obviously didn't tell
her it was because she was a porn star
because she would have been
ashamed for the rest of her life.
And I was happy that she was honest with
me. I've done my fair share of sleeves,
but this was too much. My question
bill was, Bill, my question bill,
was it wrong for me to dump her for
some decisions she made years ago?
Should I have stayed with her?
What would have you done? Um,
well you don't want to know what I
would've done. I'm a fucking degenerate.
So lets you, you seem
like a good person. Um,
dude,
when you're trying to find the person
you're going to spend the rest of your
life with you, you have to have
a list of criteria. All right?
You sound like you're still
young, so there's no reason
to compromise. All right?
I mean,
when you get with somebody like that
and you're gonna live with them and you,
when you get with anybody, you're
taking on all of their fucking baggage.
All right?
You're only three months in
and you know people who go into
the porn industry that, you know,
it's like people will come. Comedians
were not healthy individuals. Okay.
And that is like a
specific area that I just,
this is just my own personal nonmedical
feeling that you're just not a healthy
person. Something awful happened and that
line, I just wanted to feel something.
I mean, something bad happened to
her, caused her to or self off.
I don't even want to try to guess what,
but you know,
there's nothing wrong with anything that
she did purse, you know, technically.
And she was honest with it.
It all comes down to whether or not
you want to deal with it. All right.
And if you feel that you know,
you want to deal with it and that there
was this sort of connection that you
just had,
this girl had to be in your life,
then you're going to have to
learn to live with it and get it.
MMM.
But I would be definitely,
I would definitely be concerned
with a certain mental issues.
Um,
now like she's insane.
And then I would also be concerned with,
uh,
sexual boundaries,
you know,
like would she have any and could she
remain faithful after a while and when you
settle into the seven
year itch or whatever,
yeah.
And you really start needing to work at
the relationship and it's feeling boring
and she needs to feel something again.
Is she going to go back to that right
leather couch from that show?
Martin, my end, you know,
down on fog in the valley. And get
banged again. I mean, I don't know.
I Dunno. That is a, uh,
okay.
That is, you know what,
that is beyond my skills.
I don't know how to tame that horse.
I can tell you that right fucking now.
I have no fucking clue. That's a a, you
know what? That's a doctor drew question.
That is a classic doctor drew question
and that guy within two seconds we'll get
right to the core of it. I would
call, I would call in love line man,
if you're out here, call him up. Cause
that's a, that's a great one. Um,
okay.
Yeah,
I guess you'd have to figure out is is
has she works through whatever the fuck
she was working through
and now she's ready to
okay.
I mean,
I don't know.
Hey those are some good looking
girls down there and she's like,
yeah they are or whatever. Like, I mean
if you kept steering it in that direction,
you'd probably get you fucking
threesome right there. Um,
okay.
So there's that,
there's that option.
The option that you have is if you're
with her. Like I think he, I mean that,
that's,
that's a selfish fucking and I,
and a shallow reason to stay
with somebody long term,
uh,
that you,
I don't know.
Hey,
what's going on the Monday
morning podcast and uh,
I gotta admit I'm a little tired today.
I drank too much yesterday.
I don't know what the hell happened
to some bar out here in la.
And uh, I was watching the
patriots playing the 40 niners
and I get caught up in it and I had a
couple of beers drinking cores light.
I mean, it's like water, right?
And like fucking four of those.
And somehow I started doing shots and I
was, oh, next thing you know, I had to,
I had to call a cab and
actually flagged one down,
which is practically impossible in la.
And I had to just,
you know, go back and rescue
my car later on that, that,
that's how early football
comes on out here.
I actually got shit
faced watching the game,
took a cab home, passed out, sobered up,
and was able to go back and get
my car and it was still light out.
That's how early the games come
on out here. Isn't that amazing?
Christ, what the fuck is
my phone ringing my phone?
Shit, hang on a second. Hey Paul.
Hey, let me call you right
back. All right. Ima uh,
yeah,
that dude's calling me back cause I just
left him a message telling them about
fucking sports radio. He lived
from this dude. His name's Paul.
He fucking, he fucking, he listens
to sports. Very listen to me.
I'm a mess today. All right, let's
get focused here. He listens to a,
that's sports talk radio, which
uh, you know, I finally discovered,
uh, that ESPN radio thing out here on
the am station by accident and you know,
they got it. They have these
triple header baseball games.
So I like listening to the Games
like Michael K and those guys.
I think those guys are great.
I love listening to the Games,
but the sports talk radio,
it's just so ridiculous.
It's like,
I dunno.
And then I just feel like they just
deliberately saying shit to get people to
call in and you yell, you know,
really bill, does that what you think?
Do you think people deliberately do that
so their ratings are higher so they can
make more money and fucking pay
a mortgage on a bigger house?
Why didn't, that was just one of the
dumbest statements I've ever heard.
You don't want, I think they
do. I think they use gimmicks.
Some more people listen, so they
make more money. While bill,
you'll really going out on a fucking
limb there on Shah is basically what
happened last night.
My Red Sox were playing the angels was
one of the best baseball games I've seen
in a long time.
It's why baseball's a great sport.
It's why playoff baseball is awesome.
It's why I love the five game series
because every game is so huge.
So I'm listening to fucking
douchebags talking about the game.
And uh, this guy actually makes a
statement. He goes, uh, you know,
I think the red sox last night were raw,
taking the angels lightly. You know,
I think they thought that they were going
to come back to Boston and a day we're
going to close it out.
[inaudible] it's like really,
really well.
Why do they always do that when one,
that's what I hate about sports talk
radio is they can never give credit to the
team that wins.
They always got to trash the team that
loses and just talk about how they fucked
up. So, so using that analogy,
that means that the angels,
the reason why is the red sox won the
first game was because the angels would
taking the red sox slightly. And then
when gain two came along, the angel said,
Hey, you know what? I got a good idea. Why
don't we take the red sox lightly again?
And then the third game came along and
then they said, hey, wait a minute.
It's the playoffs.
Let's take the red sox seriously.
And then fortunately that same night,
the red sox for some reason decided to go,
oh, hey, let's take the
angels lightly. You know,
you know what that meant that that's the
same mentality of when the giants won
the super bowl.
I still don't feel like the giants got
the fucking credit that they deserve for
having one of the most undisputable
championships of all time.
They beat Dallas in Dallas.
They be Green Bay in Green Bay.
They fucking bill the last game
of the season we played them.
They scored 35 fucking points on us,
only lost by three clearly showing that
they were among the elite and everybody
ignored it.
There was 17 point fucking underdogs and
it was all this fucking bullshit hype.
I don't know. Meanwhile the Patriots
of squeaking by winning games,
we beat the ravens cause they fucked up.
That was in November.
Everybody just ignores that
and they just ride the hype.
And when the hype doesn't play out then
they got to figure out, I don't know,
I'm saying it was the
fucking giants for the shit.
And they kicked the shit out of
the top three teams in the league,
which means they are the baddest team of
last year and looking on this year they
won like 44 to nothing or 44 to three.
I don't know.
So I'm saying so all I'm saying is
tonight it's going to be a great game and
whoever wins the game is because they
played better now cause the other team
wasn't trying.
It's like you have a play a video game
with some fucking Douche bag and he
thinks he's the shit
and then you beat him.
And then rather than him admitting it, he
just goes to, or it wasn't even trying,
it was even trying. Then he packs up his
little fucking Atari and he goes home.
You know, it's just, this is
fucking stupid. I don't know why.
Why do people listen to sports talk radio
as that so they can then call in with
their dumb theories. You know, you know,
I thank God for ourselves is deliberately
overweight because he's trying to have
a heart attack during a
game because, uh, you know,
coaching football just got
too easy for him. I mean,
that's why you never want to super
bowl with the judge to the cowboys.
He was just bored. Oh, that's interesting.
Let's discuss that for an hour.
God knows we have five hours of
radio to fill. You know, it is,
I'm just mad at myself. It's because, um,
about a year ago I figured out how to
watch sports because it was annoying me.
Like, uh, just how big they had gotten.
And I was really starting to have a
theory that people who aren't even into
sports or watching sports now because
they're so fucking over height,
you know what I mean? It's kind of like
me. When Star Wars finally came back,
I went and I saw that first episode.
All right,
forgetting that I fucking hated star wars.
I didn't hate it. I just didn't have that
Jesus Freak. You know what I'm saying?
It's just like, yeah, you know, I
like sesame street when I was a kid,
but when the muppets
come up with a new movie,
I'm not going to go see it
because I'm fucking old now.
You know what?
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
I just totally lost my train of
thought. They'll fucktard. Well,
where the hell did I kind of, they
get to that point. All right, let's,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Uh, I think it's built bar. You know,
obviously he came to my page. I do one
of these every single Monday. And, uh,
he said, you can subscribe to this
podcast right here on my website,
[inaudible] dot com or if
you're on my myspace page,
just go to www dot [inaudible]
dot com you can subscribe to it.
You can download it on your iPod. You
can do all that wonderful stuff. And, uh,
I can become part of your life
for a half hour every Monday.
Try to put a smile on your face
at the beginning of the work week,
isn't La all right.
Last week and was riffing
above directors in the 1920s.
And I was trying to remember what the
fuck was that thing that they yelled
through that fucking battery free
bullhorn and a megaphones bullhorn.
Wait a minute. A bullhorn is
the one with that Jesus Christ.
A bull horns. The one like, uh,
that's the modern day one on tension.
We have,
you're surrounded,
weighing down your weapons and come
up with Dan's up than any comp ever.
Really say that my intention.
You know what?
I bet when they get in that situation
they don't know what to say.
Cause like all that dialogue
is so in their head. I mean,
what else are you supposed to say?
Excuse me,
I'm a police officer. All right. Anyway,
so the thing that you yell through that,
uh,
that's erectors UC yell through
way back in the day and action cut,
print it, whatever. I guess
it's called a megaphone. It's a,
it's a megaphone.
And somebody told me,
I guess back in the day they
called it a speaking trumpet,
speaking trumpet, but a megaphone.
And then the person said, yes,
I listened to podcast for that long.
Jesus,
I know last week's was really long.
It was like 40 minutes long. I Dunno.
I these things getting too long.
Was he saying that's the one thing
when somebody sends you an email,
like you can't tell like how they mean it,
you know what I mean?
And they make fun of themselves. It's all
up to the interpretation of the reader.
All right. So anyways, if
you're new to my podcast,
I do one of these every
single Monday and I, uh,
I answered questions and I learned
stuff like I learned this week. Uh,
the original bull horn was a
megaphone or a speaking trumpet.
And there is something that you can sell
somebody at a party right before you're
going to get laid to switch it into, oh,
wait a minute, you're not getting late.
And, uh, people send me and movie
reviews, overrated, underrated,
and I babbled about shit.
Um,
I actually did a college out
now in Phoenix this week,
this aeronautical college.
And I got to admit I had to
look up aeronautical and I
still don't know what the
fuck it means. Um, I think it's the, the
one, is it the science of
space or something like that?
These guys basically. All right.
The kids. Okay. The 2021 years old,
which was a kid to me cause I'm 40.
Right. And they know how to fly planes.
Some of them they're
designing planes and they uh,
I dunno. Weaponry. I have no idea. All
I know is when they have a job fair,
the fucking CIA shows up, which
is a, it's pretty intense,
Huh? That when they
show up there, you know,
have like the men in black suits and
they have like those sunglasses with like
the fucking built in Ipod.
That's how they get them. Man.
See you like these sunglasses
kid. Hey, why don't you sign up?
He's sick of playing video games.
You want to do video games for real
when you sign up with the CIA. Okay.
Cause when you know Brent up Datto was
a fucking joke compared to what I did
last weekend.
Um,
so anyways, yeah, I had a good
weekend man. I went out there.
I'm always have a good time
when I'm out in Phoenix.
Swung by the Improv and a,
I'm not even listening what I'm saying
right now cause I'm trying to find the
first question of the week, which is
this one? Uh, this guy from Detroit. Uh,
let's see. Love the DVD bro.
Definitely well worth the wait the day.
Started listening. Money mean podcasts.
All right. Podcasts, questions.
Um,
okay.
Is being happy and being content.
The same thing.
Recently I had a discussion with some
friends at a local bar that went well into
the night. I'm undecided. All right,
well you know something.
Well actually he says he's undecided
due to the fact the majority of people I
had the discussion with were
women. Um, okay. All right.
That didn't really shed any light on it.
What are you saying?
Women are stupid or they're not a guy,
so they're going to have a different
point of view. I don't know. Okay.
As being content and being happy the same.
Uh
Huh.
I don't know.
Something about being content means that
you just kind of gave in to the shit
around you. You know, where
you just kind of like,
well I guess she's just going to be a
cunt for the rest of my life and there's
nothing I can do about
it. So, uh, but you know,
my own half the house and as long as
I'm not in the half that she's in a,
you know, I'm pretty content, you
know, set the greatest situation.
But uh, you know, it's good. I'm happy,
I'm happy when she's not in the
same room as them. You know,
I'm gonna have the most amount of people
that, you know, can we compare to,
while a lot of other people
live in, you know, well,
I mean there's people trapped in
rubble after an earthquake, you know,
I definitely got a better than
them, so, you know, I think I'm on,
I think I'm content with
world with what I got.
That's my definition of,
of half of content and being happy is a
such a weird word, Huh? Happy. How
are you? I'm happy. No one says that.
I don't say I'm happy.
Happy sounds like a lie. I don't today.
I'm good. Thanks a great. I'm a good mood.
No one ever says I'm happy. That's
one of those words that's used a lot,
but nobody really uses it.
You only use it when you write.
You write when you're typing shit.
That's all it was typing only words,
you know,
the only time you ever see happy,
it's like on the cover
of like a self help book.
How to be happy and make the 12 people
around you happier by some bald guy with
the fucking goatee.
Um,
Eh,
right.
As long as any of you can answer the
question is being happy and content the
same? Um, I don't, I don't think it is.
I think being happy is generally you're
just walking around and you're in a good
mood. You appreciate
life and a, I don't know,
you'd try to do something to a every day
to make sure he didn't waste a day or
whatever. You know what I mean?
You're not an angry cycle like me.
I guess that would be happy.
And you know how many fucking
arguments I got into this week.
I get in an argument with a
guy in a scooter. All right,
fucking guy passes me on the right
between a parked car. So I beat that. Um,
um,
you know,
first of all these fucking assholes and
these scooters out here because gas is
so expensive out here in la.
Like literally it's,
it's starting to look like Europe,
the amount of people on here,
on scooters and in vespas and all
that shit. But the funny thing is,
is secretly every guy always
wants to have a fucking Harley.
He wants to be a bad ass with fucking
tattoos and some fucking winch on the back
of his bike. You know,
doesn't have a boss.
He's a fucking outlaws and he can play
the guitar like Duane Allman. Okay.
That's what fucking guys want to do.
Okay. But the people, most guys like me,
we don't have the balls to get a fucking
motorcycle because we don't want to get
road rash and you know,
have your nose burned off when you do
a fucking face plant out on the fucking
one one-on-one one. Right? So what
happens is, is a lot of these douche bags,
now they're buying scooters and they
have a false sense of safety because it's
just the scooter and nobody
who works in emergency room,
like they'll always tell you
the worst accidents we ever see,
a motorcycle accidents.
They never say, Oh my God,
this guy was doing 45 on a
scooter and he hit a lemon tree.
And let me tell you, I have not seen
carnage like this since Vietnam.
You never hear that fucking story.
It's anyways, it's fucking ass.
And plus all of these assholes get on
these scooters and that they think that
then they, you know, it's kind of fill
in that I really wanted a motorcycle,
but I don't have the balls
to buy one kind of thing.
And they get like that
born to be wild vibe.
So this fucking moron passes me on the
right between a parked car because the
road was about ready to split
and I was going to make a left,
but he was going to go straight.
So I fucking beat that him.
And he immediately slammed on the brakes
because the light was turning yellow
and he fucking,
he backs up his scooter
to my fucking hybrid.
Okay.
This guy on a scooter screaming
at a guy in a hybrid men, it must,
it's fucking hilarious.
It's like it really was showing you
the future when we're going to have a
different, we're going to be relying
on a different kind of energy.
How the whole definition of
being a man is going to be,
it's just going to be different. The whole
marvel man thing is going to be gone,
right.
So anyway,
so he flips up his visor to reveal like
his fucking twisted up angry face in
this little Tom Selleck
mustache that he's got going on.
He's like looking for release. It's
fucking yelling at me. I was like, Dude,
you just passed me on the right
between a parked car. I didn't see you.
I didn't want to hit you.
Right.
So he keeps fucking yelling
at me and I'm just like, dude,
I'm not giving you shit.
I just don't want to run into you.
I know I'm just driving a
fucking hybrid. You dumb. Fuck.
But if you do something like that,
you know your head's going to be over
here and your mustache is going to be in
the fucking trees. So I keep
telling the guy like, dude,
I'm just beeping at me cause
I didn't see ya. All right,
I don't want to run into you. I don't
want you to get hit. And then he goes, oh,
I didn't mean to startle you.
And he flipped down his
fucking visor and then went,
oh boy. And a, I got to
admit I laughed my ass off,
but then was kind of pissed cause I let
a guy on a scooter get the last fucking
word and Ami.
So I got into that argument and then I
got an argument with this is all in like
within 24 hours,
I got to know argument with a TSA person
or whatever the fuck they are at the
airport.
Um,
because of their Gestapo fucking attitude.
And then I got into an
argument when I was in Phoenix,
I was driving under the
budget, rent a car. And, uh,
I was looking down at my directions cause
I trying to figure out how to get to
the hotel and this fucking cop in shorts.
I don't know if it was rent a cop or
a real cop. I don't know what he was.
And bicycle shorts was, you
know, he was directing traffic.
So he's telling me to go, but I'm looking
down at my directions and he's like,
hello, hello? Like yelling at me like
I'm a moron. Like I didn't see him.
I did fucking see him. I just want to
make sure it was going the right way.
So I just snapped and I was holding
up the directions and I just started
screaming. I'm reading the
directions, I'm just reading me Sarah.
I kept saying, sir, rather, but, but
the undertone was you fucking asshole.
Which I couldn't say because I didn't
know if he had the authority to arrest me
and uh, I don't know.
It's just bad. You know,
that's another thing that I can't
fucking stand about America right now.
Is this too many variations
on the police officer outfit.
And I think there's a lot of times that
people aren't cops and you give them the
respect like they are cops. I'm
going to guess. You know what I mean?
When you don't have to, like I don't have
to take shit from a fucking meter maid.
I really don't.
You know what I mean?
Like this morning I made like I made like
an illegal u turn and then I saw that,
you know,
this fucking person meter maid sort of
looking at me and I got nervous for half
a second. I was like, wait a minute, it's
a fucking Meta me. What are you gonna do?
Throw it three little fucking pencil.
Lamean can they do anything
to me? Like if they said, hey,
that's an illegal u turn. And I said,
hey, why don't you go fuck yourself?
Can I do that?
You know,
I really wanna I really wish I knew my
rights more because I think there's a lot
of times you don't like that guy is I
drove by, I go, dude, I'm just, I'm sorry,
I'm just reading my directions.
He goes,
well that's why we don't
read when we drive. Really?
That's why we don't eat
whoppers with cheese when we
drive either. You Fat. Fuck.
That's what I wanted to say. But you
know, I stopped myself because I was like,
well, wait a minute. What if that's
a real cop? You know what I mean?
Thomas would have been worth it just
to see him running after me and those
fucking bike shorts. That was
my favorite part of the, uh,
that reservoir dogs movie Jvc.
When Steve Buscemi,
he's running down the street
and he shoots, you know,
after he gets hit by the car and he
turns around and he shoots those at those
three cops, they actually hits one
of them. And as he's driving away,
you see in and out his back windshield is,
do you see that one copper and down
the street just shooting his gun?
Um,
that's what I would have got to see.
Like if he was fucking shooting
at me, Jesus Christ. I'm
really all of, let me get,
let me get back to the fucking questions
here. All right, so a happier content.
Um, do I think that the
same thing? No, I don't.
I think content is an exception.
This is an acceptance and acceptance that,
you know what,
you're not going to make it to the NBA
and uh, you, you a, you appreciate,
I think, I dunno. What would you rather,
would you rather be
happy or content happy?
Just sounds like you're fucking in denial,
you know what I mean?
Do you just fucking walking
around? Hey, it is great. It
is great. No, it isn't. No,
it isn't. Banks are failing. $10
billion a month is four to fucking war.
You know, everything isn't great.
Everything's Kinda fucked up right now.
I'll speak into that shit.
You know,
people always make fun of me with my
conspiracy theories and that type of shit.
You know how they're eventually going
to stick a microchip in the back of your
head. And I've been doing this bit on
stage talking about how they start slow.
They start with dogs.
That's the first thing they start with.
And everything's cute.
Oh good.
I found fluffy and then they
graduate going to work on
the kids. And sure enough,
there's a fucking commercial
outright now with this lady.
Lady can't find her kid and
she's freaking out in the park.
So she takes out a device,
okay.
And she fucking hit some buttons and
then all of a sudden the end of the
commercial,
she finds her fucking kid.
Now the thing is is they never
showed a device on the kid.
He didn't have a wristband,
there was nothing in his, uh,
he didn't have a funny hat
with a propeller on it with
an antenna coming out of
it. Nothing. She just fucking had
that little thing and they found it.
And the funny thing was the commercial
is for batteries. And I'm telling you,
they are working towards
putting microchips in kids
that they're going to do it.
And it's all going to be done with
fear as they always do it. Oh my God,
I can't find my kid. Oh,
there he is. Thank God.
You know,
I thank God I put a fucking microchip in
my child and now I'm able to find them.
You know what I mean? And they're
gonna use fair and the reality,
they're going to put all your
information on that ship from your bank
information, your, uh,
your social security number,
everything you fucking resume to,
you'll just be getting scanned.
And the conspiracy theory is though,
is if the powers that be
ever turn your chip off,
everything you've ever done is gone.
Your money, you records everything,
it's all gone and you're fucked
and you are immediately homeless.
So that will,
that will be the ultimate level of power.
Plus they'll always know where
you are. Oh my God. It's put the,
you know what?
They're going to fucking do it.
They're going to get away with it
because all you got to use his fear
is anybody else seen that commercial
and it fucking creeps them out. Anybody?
Am I seriously the only one here? Just
kind of going nuts here. All right,
let's move on to the next fucking
question here. All right. Um, uh,
where are we a blah, blah, blah. You
mentioned being a Stevie Ray Vaughan fan.
Did you ever see him? Um, yes I did.
I saw him on the instep tour and on
the summer of 1989 at great woods in
Mansfield,
Massachusetts,
and I was fucking loaded and I remember
I was with my brother and he ended up
getting into a fight with some guy,
an argument with some guy who was easily
three times the size of me and I'm
bigger than my brother. So I just
remember like going through it, uh,
you know, what are you trying to do? I,
whenever the guy had a big orange
mesh shirt with a Jimmy buffet hat,
and you remember those sunglasses from
the 80s with either had the neon green or
orange, I think he had
the orange ones. I mean,
in retrospect, I could see why my
brother was yelling at him, but you know,
you know what I mean? I came there
for a, an evening of blues music.
I didn't want to fucking roll
around the floor with some fat fuck.
And then I have that Mesh imprint on my
face when it's fat torso landed on me.
All right, next question, uh,
is the U S U s is the UFC?
Look how fucking like what alcohol
does to me. Why do I keep drinking it?
Is the UFC jamming too
much down our throats?
Do you think the UFC is somewhat of a
fad that'll end up bearing itself or do
you think that it will be us
three with us for a long time? Um,
no, I think, I don't think the UFC is
jamming too much down our throats. Uh,
what do you mean there's too many shows?
What they got the tap out show,
they got the other one. I Dunno.
I like all those shows and uh,
I dunno. I don't think it's going to
end boxing either. I think they're both,
you know, I mean, I even want
like those tough man competitions.
You put two guys in a ring who are going
to try to beat the shit out of each
other and how do you not watch it?
It's great. It's almost even better.
Like some of those
amateur ones where they,
they don't not have fight and they fill
those haymakers and the guy gets the
other guy gets knocked out with five
basically getting hit with the palm and
risk of the other guy. You
know, those, the [inaudible].
That's why I think about barroom brawls.
They throw punches like black girls.
You have to see black girls.
They do that fucking,
you know Damon Wayans bit he does about
the windmills thing that they get going.
That's how a lot of fucking
a barroom brawls look like.
I guess.
You know what it is is because you're
not a professional fighter and you're not
calm. So even if you know
how to fight, you don't, you
don't throw, you know, Jabs,
upper cuts, you deserve. You
just basically espousing up,
which is always, that's always
fun to watch. All right,
moving onto the next thing here.
What else do we got? Oh, you know,
why do I hype some shit that I've got
coming up next week? I'm a really excited,
um,
I'm very content.
I'm very happy with the fact that next
week for the first time ever I will be
performing in Austin,
Texas at the cap city comedy
called and it's part of the uh,
the uninformed tour, um, which
is the radio show I do with uh,
Joe de Rosa who will be opening for me
out there at the Cap City Comedy Club in
Austin, Texas. Uh,
and I will be there from August 16th
through the 18th and a on the 18th.
I will in fact be going to the
Texas Longhorns, Missouri Games.
So take out your binoculars because
I will be one of the people,
one of the 100,000 people at the game.
And uh,
if you would like to get tickets anyways
to go to the Austin thing, a Oxman show,
go to a cap city comedy club.com and
a click right on the tickets thing.
I'm on the website right now. There
it is. Look at that. There it is.
Who's going to be the, and some guy
named Matt Sadler's there this week.
So if you want to look at the room,
go see him,
look at me hype and other guys
fucking shows. All right, so is that,
is that going to be it? Oh, hey,
let's do overrated. Underrated.
I didn't really get any this week, so, um,
or at least I can't find any that I got.
Um, I'm going to tell you my fucking, you
know what I think is overrated. You know,
it's overrated. Japanese, uh, baseball.
Wait a minute, somebody said that,
didn't they?
They already said that on this one.
Somebody said that Japanese baseball
players are overrated. And you know what?
I have to agree with them after
watching dice k pitch game too,
and when he came over,
oh,
the fucking gyro ball and all
that type of type of stuff.
These Japanese baseball players,
they always have these
ridiculous nicknames like
they're going to be, you know,
you know,
they're always named like titled in
Godzilla and then they come over here.
So we're going to miss
strike three had decky Ema,
now I can talk to act goes down again.
He's in a bit of a slump and it's amazing.
He hit 9,000 home runs over in the Osaka.
You know, why don't they just
go to the Dominican Republic?
That's where they all are. I mean,
how many fucking Pedro Martinez?
You know what I mean?
Like a Manny Ramirez.
But what the fuck he's
done for the Dodgers. Okay.
And he's just from Washington Heights.
All right.
But if you actually go to to the,
to the fountain, to the source,
anything down there. Puerto Rico. Yeah.
You got to respect that. That dom
isn't that where many Rivera's from
David Ortiz doesn't need Dominican?
Why wouldn't you go there?
Look at those guys. The fucking
insane. I mean, I think you've got to,
you got to go Latino firms. I'm going
to, I'm going to send it out there.
Latinos have taken over
Latinos saved baseball.
You know,
people always talking about how black
dudes took over hoop and they took over a
football and all that type of ship
and no one's bringing up a baseball.
All these fucking guys, right? I just
don't know enough baseball players.
But anytime I see somebody doing like,
you know,
turning a double play with his back to
second base and he doesn't even take the
ball out of his glove and he fucking
flips it over there with his club.
It's always a Latino dude are some
of the top white Jesus Christ.
There are many white guys left.
Really getting low self esteem here.
When his second Ukeles
wow was just fucked up. I
am hard pressed. Who is,
who is the best white guy is a question
for you guys. Who's the best white guy?
Baseball player outright.
Now I'm really drawing a
blank half of Derek Jeter.
Can we get credit for that?
Um,
well let's look at the red sox.
Jason Varitek calls a great game.
He's batting about fucking Oh 25 Euclid.
Kevin Lowe,
Jason Bay.
Adroit Jesus Christ.
Wait a minute.
You know, I can't think of one fucking,
you know. No, this is bullshit.
This is bullshit. That's gotta be one.
I'm just throwing fucking drawing a blank.
Let's go to the Yankees. They was going
to a zillion stars. All right. Hey Rod.
Okay. Hey, Rod Rodriguez. Okay. He's
not white. Derek Jeter get half credit.
Second base, uh, the
fuck, that's not Soriano.
What the fuck play second base.
I know who he is.
He looks like fucking a Ralph Harris.
That's not a white dude. Jason
Giambi. I mean Jesus Christ.
Fucking guys on a, these are like horse
tranquilizers. You have another set guy.
He fucking hits the ball.
He just starts running down the line,
licking his lips and he's always sweaty.
Got that crazy fucking look in his eye.
Like he wants to admit to a
murder, but he, but he can't.
Then you go out to the outfield.
Who Do they got? I don't know.
Random fucking figured stuff.
You know what I, my brain hearts,
I think we got Tom Brady. Tom
Brady is the AMT. Wes Walker.
They ain't go, I can not tell you
something right now. You know,
I did a bit on my last special about how,
you know,
whenever you watch the Olympics,
whenever you watched the track race has
always nine black dudes and at one token
white guy in lane eight,
you know,
and I'll not the other
nine black dudes bomb away.
I don't know if you've noticed
during this Olympics. I Dunno.
I dunno what new synthetic drug is out
there that they don't know how to test
for. But I think that they, they're
giving it to some white dudes because uh,
that was someone,
some of the fastest white people I've
seen in a long time and I was just sitting
there like fourth place.
Really? Wow. They were flying.
Well, the short shorts, I think
the white dudes coming back. Yeah.
Well I'm going to, I'm going to
fucking go out on a limb here.
I'm going to say that uh,
blacks and Latinos have raised the
bar and Chinese people in Ping Pong.
Not to be disrespectful, you know, want
to make sure I include everybody and uh,
now we're going to raise the bar. Hey
listen, the question I've got for you,
how come only USC seems to
know that Samoans make great
linebackers or defensive
backs. Every time you get fucking
watching UFC, they always got some,
some new motto.
Follow guy with fucking a 12 inch Afro
mullet coming out of the back of his
helmet. Just lighten people
up. Did Samoans only say,
I'm only playing in southern California
because that's the closest thing to the
beautiful weather we have in the islands,
Samoa. You know what I just realized,
I have no idea where the ILS Samoa is.
I'm going to guess it's a south of
Hawaii in a little further east now.
Live a little further west.
Got Him stupid.
That doesn't make you stupid, does
it? I don't know. All right. Anyways,
this has been the podcast for this week.
It's been very disjointed,
very hung over.
My voice is tired and uh,
and when I was telling you
I was quitting drinking,
well obviously I've stopped
and uh, you know, I don't,
I don't have to do about
it. It's just fun. You know,
it's like that guy said he's sitting
there bar and he got new big an all night
debate over. What's the difference
between happy and content?
You know what I mean? It's a, you know,
it's good discussion considering
everybody has air conditioning nowadays,
so no one hangs out on the stoops anymore,
so you can't shoot the shit.
You go down to the bar and
you have great discussions.
It was a good one. I had the, it was
a fucking, when I had the other day,
who was one of those,
what would you rather be?
Would you rather be gay or
would you rather be tortured?
That's what came,
that's what came through.
You know,
that fucking dilemma
was like an hour debate.
What would you rather be?
Would you rather be gay or would
you rather be tortured? All right.
Now I believe that you're born gay.
Okay.
So it was a bad question because
what they should have said,
would you rather be forced to be
straight and forced to perform a gay act?
Or would you rather be
tortured but to just say,
would you rather be gay or be tortured?
It's a no brainer.
You'd rather be gay because you born
that way. You just came out going, hey,
I'll loving the cock. You know, it's like
Lichen cookies. You like it. That's like,
what?
Did you run any cookies or have someone
take a pliers and remove one of your
fingers? Ah, I think
I'd eat the cookies. So
now, you know what I mean? I, I'm, I'm of
that school. I believe you're born gay,
you know, I don't understand these
people who think is a choice.
Why would you choose that? You know,
everyone, if you could make a choice,
you're trying to be a quote unquote
as normal as humanly possible,
unless you like Madonna and you're
just like an attention whore.
You know what I mean? So you just
deliberately, you know, finally jumpsuits.
Did you just yank up between your Twat
lifts? What does with her? You know,
it's like lady you 50. I got it. You're in
shape, but I don't, you're, you're weird.
Look. And now they just weird
looking because the loan you,
she looks like an old stripper,
you know?
Fucking put the God damn glass
high heels away lady. It's over.
If 50 yeah.
Had a great run.
People have been fucking rubbing
one out to you for since the 80s.
That's unprecedented that it's,
it's three decades.
You know, I think you got enough.
Think you've had enough. All right.
Oh wait a minute before I
wrap this up here. This is,
somebody sent me this thing.
Um, uh, what is this? I actually,
I didn't know where to file this
under other than just an op ed piece.
All these are the movie reviews.
What am I talking about?
Someone actually made up a great one here.
They said they gave me a good,
when they said my number one worst movie
of all time time was m night Shambhala
limit Dingdong whatever his fucking
name is. Uh, that movie, the village.
But now pineapple express has
taken its place. Horrible movie.
I guess you have to smoke weed to get it.
Although half baked was hilarious.
Now
I think you made a great point there.
In the end we said you know, half,
but you know,
you think Pineapple Express was the
worst movie ever but you like half baked.
And I'm going to say that's because
half bake came out 10 years ago when you
were probably 18 to 21.
You know what I mean?
Cause I saw pineapple express.
I thought parts of it were funny,
but in the end I was just
like, yeah, you know,
I kind of felt like I wasted my money and
I was like, ah. It was kind of stupid.
But then I was thinking, wait
a minute, you know what? If
I was 16 to 21 years old,
pineapple express would be one of the
funniest fucking movies I ever saw.
Just because you're in
that mindset. So, you know,
so it's not even fair for me
to say that star wars sucks.
Now you know what it is.
Because I remember I thought the way
he walks for gay way back in the day,
and by gay, I don't mean, uh,
I don't mean happy like the gay
nineties number, the 1890s, everybody,
they would call it the gay nineties
before gay switched to meaning.
You like to have sex with
someone of the same sex.
And I don't mean gay as in,
uh,
yeah, homosexual. I mean that other
kind of gay, you know what I mean?
You want to do that, that's fucking
gay. That doesn't even mean stupid.
What the can may give me a good
definition, but that's one of those,
everybody knows what it means,
but she can't give it a definition.
Doesn't mean happy.
It doesn't mean homophobic.
It's that inbetween said gray area of gay,
like uh, uh, jam bands.
That's fucking gay.
I don't watch somebody play a
fucking guitar solo for 90 minutes.
That's not even a good example.
I'm the fucking worst.
Why don't I prepare for these
things? All right, here's, yeah,
well this is the last thing I'll read.
This is some op ed piece feeling I,
because this wasn't a question,
it didn't fit into any category.
It was just somebody opinion. So
this might start something new. Um,
okay. Here we go. Bill. Nowadays,
the majority of men are such wimps that
there is no hope for a woman meeting.
A decent man that isn't a pussy.
Most men have no shame
admitting that they are weak.
And I seriously wonder myself,
where have all the man,
where's all the manhood gone? Didn't
men use to feel good about being manly?
Have we as strong women, quote unquote
taking it away? My grandfather,
my grandfather would rolling over in
his grave if he heard how pussified most
men have become it.
It's very sad. However,
it has caused me to
stand on my own two feet.
So I never have to rely on a weakling,
which is good because I don't want
anyone else running my ruining. I mean,
running my life about myself.
Um, and then it just goes on.
And it wasn't our fault that men have
weakened, uh, and been feminized.
So
have women become so strong that men
are afraid to take their rollback?
That's a ridiculous question.
Oh yeah. Yeah. We're terrified.
Have we lost because we've won either
way. It sucks. Smell. You know what?
This is sweetheart.
This,
I dunno if it has to do with your hormones
or what it has to do with a woman.
Never for the most part,
never really knowing what she wants
or what's going to make her happy.
And you become psychotically focused
on something and then when you get it,
you are still not fulfilled,
which causes you to question everything.
And uh, I dunno, I don't think,
I dunno.
What,
what are you basing nowadays that the
majority of men are such wimps that,
you know, are you basing that on
like the television you're watching?
Because I definitely think that we are
in a streak here where they, you know,
I think always throughout the history of
time with like sitcoms and that type of
stuff that they,
uh,
they always had to make the guy
like dumber and the woman's smarter.
And,
uh,
I just think they do that as an apology
for the fact that for the most part guys
run shit and uh,
don't let women get past a certain point
in management. So I think that they, the,
you know,
to throw you a bone,
they make the guy character a fucking
idiot in the, uh, in the Sitcom.
But at the end of the day, who wants to
show some studio that's run by some guy?
So who gives a fuck? So,
I dunno, I think you're,
you're probably fishing in the
wrong pond. Um, but you know,
be careful what you wish for.
Uh,
because the quote unquote real
man is a probably an asshole,
I would think.
I don't know what the fuck do I know?
I don't fucking know anything.
Have guys become pussified.
I think a lot of the comedies,
like you know a lot of them,
like these hipster fucking
Douche bags out there that, that,
that kind of in right now.
Maybe that's what you're basing it on.
How they were those stupid
fedoras and it's just a fucking,
I don't know what it is. I hate
the fucking, you know. Dot.
That that whole fucking, that whole
scene just bugs the shit out of me.
Fucking idiots walked around there for
doors like deliberately dressing like
nerds. It's like, dude, you are a
nerd. You don't have to try. Okay.
And stop acting like you
were cool in high school.
Stop trying to rewrite your story.
All right. You weren't cool,
you weren't getting any pussy
and now you know, and it's just,
I fucking hate that whole thing. I
think that's all. But you know what I,
you know I'm really sick of
though, is, is the word awkward?
You know what I mean? I'm
sick of awkward comedy. Like,
do you guys watch that show? The
office? I can't deal with that show.
It's just like,
can some person,
can one person on that show be
aware of what they're saying?
It's just everything that happens
on that show and it's like,
and then my house burned down,
not good.
And then they sort of look around like,
wait a minute, what did I just say?
It's just fucking, it's ridiculous.
I'm sick of that kind of comedy.
Yeah. The, I'm calling it first
awkward comedy is out. All right.
And if it's somehow spin
back to false anger,
I get my own goddamn show.
All right. That's it. How
long have I talked this week?
42 minutes. These things are
getting too long, I think. I mean,
I'm making fun of jam bands and I'm
having 42 minute fucking podcast.
Why don't I get to the point a little
quicker? All right. So anyways,
I am going to be at the a Cap
City Comedy Club in Austin,
Texas on a fucking October
16th 17th and 18th.
Go to Cap City Comedy club.com
to get your tickets. Um,
if you're listening to this on my space,
please check out my new website.
It's a work in progress.
A billboard.com and check out all the
stuff that I got going on there and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. I'll
talk to you guys next week.
Thank you for listening and I hope
you're happy. Help your content.
You happy this week? All right. That's
it. All right. Have a good week.
So
[inaudible].